several videos ago I had a figure that
looked something like this I believe it
was a Pentagon or a hexagon and what we
had to do is figure out the sum of the
particular exterior angles of the
hexagon so it would have been this angle
which call a this angle B C D and E and
the way that we did the last time we
said well a is going to be 180 degrees
minus the interior angle that is
supplementary to a and then we did that
for each of the angles and then we
figured out we were able to
algebraically manipulate it we were able
to figure out what the sum of the
interior angles were using dividing it
up into triangles and then use that to
figure out the exterior angles and it
was a bit of an involved process what I
want to show you in this video is
there's actually a pretty simple and
elegant way to figure out the sum of
these particular external angles
exterior angles I should say of this
polygon and it actually works for any
convex polygons when you're picking
these particular external these
particular exterior angles I should say
and so the way to think about it is you
can just redraw the angles so let's
let's just draw each of them so let me
let me draw this angle right over here
we could call it angle a or maybe the
measure of this angle is a either way
let me draw it right over here
so it's going to be this is going to be
a congruent angle right over here it's
going to have a measure of a now let me
draw angle B angle B and I'm going to
draw it adjacent to angle a and what you
could do is think about it maybe if we
would do a line right over here if we
drew a line right over here that was
parallel to this line then the measure
of this angle right over here would also
be B because this obviously is a
straight line it would be like a
transversal these are corresponding
angles so if we wanted to draw an
adjacent angle B adjacent to a you could
do it like that or the whatever angle
this is its measures B then now it's
adjacent to a and now let's draw the
same thing for C we could draw a
parallel line to that right over here
and then this angle would also be C and
if we want it to be adjacent to that we
could draw it right over here so that
angle is C so C would look something
like this
see would look something like that then
we can move on to D once again let me do
that in a different color you could do D
D could be right over here
or you could shift it down over here
look like that or you could shift it
over here to look like that if we just
kept thinking about parallel if all of
these lines were parallel to each other
so let's just draw D like this let's
just draw a D like this do you like this
so this line once again is going to be
parallel to that line and then finally
you have e finally you have angle D and
once again you could draw a line you
could draw a line that is parallel to
this right over here right over here and
this right over here would be angle E or
you could draw it right over here you
would draw it right over here and when
you see it drawn this way it's clear
that when you add up the measure this
angle a B C D and E you're going all the
way around the circle
either way you could be going you could
be going clockwise or you could be going
counterclockwise but you're going all
the way around the circle and so the sum
of these angles are just going to be so
a plus B plus C plus D plus E is just
going to be 360 degrees and this will
actually work as I said for any convex
polygon when I say a convex polygon that
one I mean one that's not dented inwards
one that's kind of so just to be clear
what I'm talking about it would work for
any cut any polygon that is that is kind
of that I don't want to say regular
regular means it has the same signs and
same angles but it's not dented so this
is this is a con so this is a convex
polygon this right here is a concave
polygon so let me draw it this way so
this right over here would be a concave
would be a concave polygon I'm going to
draw it as a as a having the same number
of sides so I just kind of dented these
two sides right over here there and did
I do that right let me see let me do the
same number of sides so I want to do
that that that that and then I know
that's the same side over there let me
let me draw it like that and then like
that this has 1 2 3 4 5 6 sides this has
1 2
three four five six sides this is
concave sorry
this is convex this is a convex polygon
this is a concave polygon the way I
remember is it is kind of caved in words
and so what we just did would apply to
any if we're trying to find these
particular external exterior angles of
any convex polygon I afraid I apologize
ahead of time if I've confused them all
because I have a feeling that I might
have this applies to any convex polygon
and so once again if you take if you
take this angle and add it to this angle
and add it to this angle add it to this
angle add it to that angle and add it to
that angle and I'm not implying that
they're all going to be the same I just
drew it that way I could show you that
they are different angles so I could say
that when in green and that one in some
other color I think you get the idea
they can all be different but when you
if you shift the angles like this you'll
see that they just go around the circle
so once again they'll just add up to 360
degrees